we couldn't finish this last episode of
the season of the pledge without a look
back at some of our best and worst
behind-the-scenes bits from Oz months
we've had more drama than the drug
admissions in the Tory leadership
contests more arguments than love Island
more excitement then the Women's World
Cup more innuendos than Boris Johnson in
a sausage factory with his icing sugar
and more people stuck in the studio than
an extinction rebellion protests it's
safe to say that it's been a blast
hello and welcome to the pledge podcast
I'm Trevor
it said I'm Rachel Johnson maxvill is
very throat he's gonna be on the pledge
you know found panel now I'm told by all
sorts of experts that within two years
I'll be able to work alone one mannequin
mannequin that's the stress yes when
woman akin to a mannequin so nice load
in the last week alone he's got the
blame for the government having to give
cut music to be serious
something got me in a bit of a larger
this week in fact I was virtually
foaming with rage the hashtag me to move
exactly can you say that no Rachel quite
an extraordinary thing to do stick it up
oh you like to laugh at pussycat okay
[ __ ]
there we go done okay all right just
that's it for this week this series of
the pledge buck if you want to join in
the debate just search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter and you can now
listen to the program on the go with
acne podcasts thanks for watching and
we'll see you in September
[Music]